we've got a uh
break breaking news maybe this is a
little breaking news action oh well
michael saylor just tweeted this uh
more bitcoin pretty good no
uh bitcoins
he said bitfarms deposited 96 of their
bitcoin production into custody this
year rather than sell it on the open
market if other publicly traded miners
do the same bitcoin stock the flow is
going to infinity then it is going
negative this is not factored into
anyone's model michael saylor coming out
king [ __ ] right here that's what's going
on when you say that the stock to flow
is going to infinity
and then it is going negative this is
not factored into anyone's model you
better have a pretty good reason for
saying that and his point is that bit
farms a publicly traded entity deposited
96
of what they mined into custody rather
than selling it for dollars so when
these institutions these organizations
or individuals continue to stack sats
whether you're a big publicly traded
mining firm or you're an individual
sitting at home literally buying a
dollar a day when you continue to stack
sats it continues to pull supply out of
the market and it increases that
illiquid supply will's coming on uh in a
few minutes and we're going to talk
explicitly about this idea but we're
seeing now publicly traded businesses 96
of what they produced or their revenue
in bitcoin ends up getting put into
storage
not being sold on the market you just
don't have nearly as much cell pressure
and so ultimately if people do that for
decades and decades and decades it ends
up creating one of the most interesting
market structures in the entire
financial markets in my opinion
yeah i think also if you look at the
chart uh it looks like they're mining a
decent amount more than they were in the
previous months you know some of that
obviously has to do with price and all
that kind of stuff also uh but if you
have someone who's mining three 400
bitcoin a month that is saying hey we're
gonna place 95 96 of this in custody
rather than go sell it out to dollars
you can quickly see how that how that
shifts uh the supply demand equation
even even more aggressively kind of in
in the favor of people that are bullish
on bitcoin fix supply
when you when you look at uh the entire
um bitcoin supply here we know that
people aren't selling and that sets up
for this idea of shocktober uh the
bigger story though is
on-chain metrics is one thing was about
to talk about that in a second retail
investors is another we have publicly
traded companies doing this and then
they explicitly are talking about it
this is a publicly traded ceo of michael
sailor microstrategy talking about
another publicly traded company strategy
doing this and so when you now get this
entering into the conversation it gets
normalized in public markets every
single corporation is going gonna start
saying hey should we be stacking stats
should we be stacking stats
what are we gonna miss this are we gonna
not participate here are we gonna hold
dollars or any other fiat currency
that's being devalued at a historic rate
or are we gonna get in the game
and at some point somebody in the
organization says hey let's not be
stupid here right the opportunity cost
is higher to not participate than to
participate let's get in the game let's
start stacking stats and let's keep it
off the uh off the market in illiquid
form the answer is yes to your question
about if they should start stacking hats
of course
of course what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]